la fête donc ce soir sur les
champs-elysées avec la marseillaise de
jean paul goude un défilé original dans
lequel certains ont vu parfois un délire
planétaire c'était une critique avec
nous en direct des champs elysées nous
avons jean paul goude et georges bégoux
jean paul goude comment est ce que vous
sentez est ce que vous êtes cool
comment vous sentez vous quoi comment
vous sentez et je pense que en ce moment
a à peine une heure du spectacle quand
on a travaillé pendant six mois on doit
avoir un peu les fois qu'on m'ont dit ça
mélange des deux d'un mélange de
délation et de trouille c'est vrai oui
et voulons jean monville répétition on
est à peu près sûr que ça va marcher et
vous oui il n'y a pas d'incidents
techniques
s'il n'y a pas un camion qui casse un
essieu ou une un problème de générateurs
commune où tu joues un problème comme ça
pendant la pétition un générateur qui
s'est arrêtée de fonctionner s'il n'y a
pas d'incident technique ça devrait
faire la rue michel
alors voyez là nous sommes je crois que
c'est l'image dont vous avez toujours
rêvé moi aussi d'ailleurs
regardez l'arc de triomphe ce ce grand
drapeau comment l'avez vous rêvez vous
cette révolution ce bicentenaire auger
pas rêver le bicentenaire j'ai rêvé un
défilé une parade
j'ai essayé de ne pas trahir le contexte
dans lequel il va se passer mais avant
tout j'ai essayé de trouver une solution
à un problème
problème comme ça non un problème que
posait c'est à dire de 2 d'arriver à
tirer mon épingle du jeu de dunes
quelque chose utile nature solennelle
qui correspond pas vraiment à ma
personnalité quand même donc je crois
qu'on est arrivé à faire une bonne
synthèse de la sérénité de la gravité
pour ce qui est des chinois et de la
fête
alors les chinois nous enverrons un tout
à l'heure à côté de moi j'ai aussi
charles gassot qui est le producteur
producteurs c'est 7 correspond à cinq ou
six films de long métrage vous allez
jouer votre tête en une soirée
oui ça on joue tous les deux notre tête
on ne saurait ça n'existait pas bien là
notre tête sur une pique ce soir à
minuit c'est clair mais c'est un film en
direct on accuse on a droit qu à une
prise qui dure deux heures
alors si vous le voulez en deux secondes
nous allons voir ce qui se passait là il
ya sur les champs elysées dans les
avenues adjacentes
je demande à ce qu'on nous passe le
petit extrait de tous ces gens qui se
préparent à se défiler de parade ce soir
cet opéra ballet où es tu je n'ai pas
trop fatigué là ça va
nous sommes les tambourinaïres de
province et vous êtes là depuis combien
de temps depuis mardi on répète nous
avons une petite fatigue quand même
parce que ça fait trois nuits
nous travaillons jusqu'à 4 heures du
matin mais enfin c'est avec grand
plaisir de le faire
et alors les montpelliérains qui sont
avec vous combien sont ils à ben pas
nombreux ils sont venus que 10 et les
autres viennent d'où de toutes les
régions de france
je suis un étudiant envoyés par le
gouvernement chinois
il ya près d'une dizaine d'années déjà
oui mais ce qu'il ya sur votre front là
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire liberté
démocratie égalité et en ce moment c'est
très important très important et la
manifestation générale de tous les amis
chinois qui sont autour de vous
peut-être contribuer à quelque chose on
espère bien oui on espère ne pas
ne pas oublier ce qui s'est passé sur la
place il ya un manque de le 4 juin et on
aimerait profiter de cette occasion pour
rappeler cet événement alors au delà du
côté un peu carnavalesque et magic
circus sur à ce côté émotionnel des
chinois parce que vous étiez en chine au
moment des événements ouais on était
allé deux fois la première fois c'était
pékin comme on la verrait le lieu commun
pékin normal pas probants et la deuxième
fois on est arrivé en pleine fête
juste et on est partis deux jours avant
le
la loi martiale donc c'était la fête si
j'avais imaginé au début de l'année en
février
tout d'un coup avait évolué avec les
événements donc comme l'a fait se
passait dans la rue et que les gens se
couvraient être calé il y avait des
calicots partout j'ai rappelé
oui j'essaye c'est j'ai essayé de faire
une parade qui correspondait à
l'atmosphère de fête du moment et puis
tout d'un coup le couperet est tombé on
est obligé de mon art si vous n'êtes me
disant que la chine ne viendrait pas
donc le char qui est ici évident georges
bigot oui un dernier mot et nous nous
quittons merci d'avoir posé toutes ces
questions yat il du monde actuellement
sur les champs-elysées sur les champs
elysées il doit y avoir un peuple un
million à un million et demi de
personnes
mais on ne peut pas vous montrer les
images vous allez les découvrir tout de
suite après le journal puisque nous
avons la chance de retransmettre en
direct ce merveilleux événement tout à
fait ce sera à 21h35 en direct sur
antenne 2